what kind of a lizard tells jokes ha
stand up chameleon we human beings are
dominant in every aspect of life as
compared to other animals this is what
we think isn't it sorry to burst your
bubble it's a misconception there are so
many things that the animals can do but
we cannot for instance we cannot change
the color of our skin but a few animals
around us can do one such animal is
chameleon
we know that the chameleons have the
tendency to change the colors of their
skin and why do they do so is there any
particular reason or is it because
chameleons also love fashion time to
unravel the truth I know what you must
be thinking now is there anything to be
curious when it comes to chameleons
changing the colors we all know that the
chameleons camouflage that is they
change their skin colors to blend with
the environment this is to essentially
hide from the Predators now what if I
say that this is a myth yes you heard me
right blending with the environment is
not the only reason for the chameleons
to change their colors and why do I say
that most of the chameleons can run up
to the speed of 21 miles per hour that's
pretty fast isn't it in addition to this
their eyes have almost 360 degree vision
and at the same time each eye can see
independently in two different
directions as the chameleons are so
Swift and also are blessed with such
unique eyesight it shouldn't be
difficult for them to stay away from the
Predators this tells us that there is
more to the story as to why the
chameleons change their skin colors
let's look at this part of the story the
color change in the chameleons is due to
the temperature moods social signaling
or other conditions confused
don't be let's understand this well
chameleons basically change their skin
colors to adjust their bodies to the
outside environment as the temperature
drops the skin may turn darker to absorb
more heat and what happens when the
temperature rises they turn into lighter
shades in order to reflect the light
from the bodies
chameleons also change their color to
reflect their moods it sounds as if the
chameleons do have mood swings okay so
now what do we mean by the chameleons
changing colors to reflect their moods
when a chameleon is enjoying its own
company it changes to lighter shades
it's considered to be in a relaxed state
on the other hand if it encounters its
rival it tends to show brighter colors
to show aggression that's not it
chameleons also change their skin colors
to attract potential mates interesting
isn't it so are these the only reasons
for a chameleon to change its colors
nope there are more when physical
pressure is applied on its skin it tends
to change its color and gets back to the
original color when the pressure is
removed so many reasons and for all our
lives were under the misconception that
the only reason for chameleons to change
their skin colors was to protect
themselves from the Predators
this was about the chameleons there are
so many other organisms like the crab
spiders cuttlefish and a few more that
change their skin colors what are their
reasons to do so this is your cue box to
explore let us know your exploration in
the comment section below and remember
never stop being curious
[Music]